you're only as strong as your weakest
leader I'll give you an example if your
head of franchise International
expansion is a killer
she or he is just like [__] making it
actually happen in Europe but they're a
piece of [__] and everybody else hates
them if you don't fire them everything I
just said is dead so one of the things I
think a lot about is never compromising
if Marcus my chief of staff who's here
day one if Claude or chief heart officer
if Sid like nobody's safe from
what I've built and if you're willing to
live that truth then you're in a much
better place so you'll be able to easily
pull it off if you're not full of [__]
if you don't choose money over culture
most people will look the other way for
someone who's dictating too much money
for them and then it's all over